graph 0.6 on the number line down here  we have a number line that goes from 0  to 1 and it's split into 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8  9 10 equal spaces these tick marks  there's 10 of these spaces all the way  from 0 to 1  so between any two of these spaces for  example between these first two tick  marks could be represented by 1/10 it's  one one of the ten equal spaces is 1/10  of the distance now the number we're  supposed to graph is 0.6  well this 6 is in the tenths place value  so another way we could read this  decimal is 6 tenths or as the fraction  six tenths so if one of these spaces  represents one out of ten equal spaces  and we want six tenths then we need to  travel six of the 10 equal spaces six  tenths of the way six of the 10 spaces  so we can start at the beginning and go  one two three four five six and graph  right here with a point and this is six  tenths